In Germany, a child is born. Let's call her Laura. Straight away, she's in the care of the church.
In Germany, every third hospital is run by
a Christian organization.
Laura is christened in a Catholic church.
She belongs to the world's largest religious
community - Christianity.
1.1 billion Christians are Roman Catholic.
800 million are Protestant, and 300 million
are Eastern Orthodox.
Christianity is a wealthy religion.
In the US, for example, faith-based business contributes
more to the economy
than the top ten technology businesses.
Churches there are financed
by donations.
In Germany, the Catholic and Lutheran churches are worth some 345 billion euros.
They own shares, real estate, breweries and
even film production companies.
Over a million people work for the churches.
That's second only to the German state, which employs
over 4.5 million.
Laura goes to Catholic daycare.
When she's older, she'll be confirmed - and
presented with the world's biggest selling book.
At least 3 billion copies of the Bible have
been sold to date - making it a nice little
earner for publishers.
As an adult, Laura will pay an additional
9 percent of her income tax as church tax.
Although many have opted to leave, the Catholic
and Lutheran churches still saw record high
takings in 2015 of 11.5 billion euros.
When Laura dies, she wants a Christian burial.
And her final resting place will be in a Catholic
cemetery.